[Musik]
für den kitzbüheler ski club ist das
österreichische bundesheer seit 1956 ein
verlässlicher partner
es ist unglaublich wie dass wir dort
eine gute ausbildung haben und sich hier
sicher in dem steilen und vereisten
bereich auf der streif am tanzen zu
bewegen bist management das ist die
hauptaufgabe
wir haben traditionell ein haben dass
soldaten im einsatz mit ihren
kommandanten also rund 16 kommandanten
dabei sind und im notfall kann das bis
150 aussteller
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so gibt es in ganz besonderer ort des
hahnenkamm rennen ist weltweit eine eine
wirkliche eine attraktion sondergleichen
und her diesmal ganz besondere freude
als der verteidigungsminister in der
republik österreich denjenigen danke zu
sagen
die dafür sorgen dass die pisten so
perfekt sein wie sie es an unseren
soldatinnen und soldaten
[Musik]
und in diesem sinn wird angenommen dass
kitzbühel schicken und herzlicher für
diesen langjährigen zusammen weiter und
hoffen und freue mich auf die zukunft